[Music]
when Champions Win Hockey games what
do they win the Stanley Cup [Music]
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
how many times yeah it's a great
experience and see the turnout
here with all the fans and stuff
they love their hockey here and
it's great to really get on the ground
so to speak and get to know everyone
yeah I think it's huge for the community anytime
you can do something like this and you know brings
everyone together and you know shows all the
support in the community has for coffee [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause] [Music]
[Music]
[Music] [Applause]
they're already
I'm here
[Music]
blue [Music]
everybody Max
it's a hockey head
stop Timmer [Music]